friday and that means it's time for
friday follies for that we go to author
of the brand new book the thief who
stole heaven
get it fox news contributor raymond
arroyo raymond
uh there is a new ad campaign i
understand making the round
some very familiar faces indeed the ad
council law
released a pair of psas featuring former
presidents and first ladies
see if you can tell who's missing here
we urge you to get vaccinated when it's
available to you
so roll up your sleeve and do your part
this is our shot
the ad council said they didn't ask
trump to join
because he wasn't at the inauguration
where they shot one ad
and they didn't realize he'd gotten the
vaccine but jimmy carter didn't go to
the inauguration law
and somehow he made the cut they also
figured out that the carters had the
vaccine so
figure that one and nevertheless the
media was quick
to point out the obvious donald trump is
not in this ad
but here are the other uh living
presidents
all sending a message about the vaccine
together it's a remarkable ad
just yet another example of how former
president donald trump is really
estranged from this president's club and
it's a very elite a group of former
presidents
look at bush bush has got the guns doing
some weight lifting
dead or alive hombre he's looking good
max headroom there um raymond
laura raymond first of all how does how
does not being part of a psa
connote being excluded or estranged from
the president's club
trump's a former president no matter how
you cut it here these people are like
political crack addicts they can't
quit the addiction to trump i mean they
see trump they wake up at night at three
in the morning
if they see trump they i mean trump is
everywhere for them so
what is he supposed to like you know
insert jump into the frame i mean
he has to be invited to be it oh god
here's my point if you're really
concerned with vaccinating people
41 percent of republicans say they don't
want the vaccine
who of that group do you think has most
sway over the republican voters
at this point probably donald trump he
should have been invited if they're
really concerned here
but laura apparently shunning is not
restricted to the former president's
club
over at the talk sharon osborne defended
her friend piers morgan
who's been pilloried for questioning
meghan markle's charges in that oprah
interview
his critics say to question markle is
itself racist i feel even
like uh i'm about to be put in the
electric
chair because i have a friend who many
people
think is a racist i've been asking you
during the break i am asking you again
and don't try and cry because if anyone
should be crying it should be me
educate me tell me when you have heard
him say
racist things it is not the
exact words of racism and i don't want
anybody here
to to watch this and say that we're
attacking you for being racist
and and that and for that if i
articulate it
oh my god laura this spat went on for a
while and actually was carried over
through a break
afterward osborne apologized in a
statement she said to anyone of of color
that i've offended and or to anyone who
feels
confused or let down by what i said i'm
truly sorry i'm
i panicked i thought blindsided etc now
piers morgan
is saying these bullies on the talk
should apologize
to him for calling him a racist i can't
believe
osborne what is she apologizing for
i don't underst i mean i don't i don't
get it she she has a friend
who is accused she believes unfairly so
the only
noble thing to do is throw your friend
to the curb and say that he must be
implicitly biased or hold it inside
because he criticized someone who
happens to be
of color so what they should say in the
talk is that you cannot criticize anyone
if the person is liberal and is of color
you cannot criticize because if you do
you're a racist that's what they should
admit to but they won't because they're
cowards i'm sorry this is
outrageous and i'm you know the osborne
i don't think i've ever watched that
[ __ ] you've got it look these are
incendiary charges that meghan markle
made
they should be discussed and confirmed
or denied otherwise we we're we're
landing in jesse smollettville and i'm a
little worried about going down that
road yeah well raymond um
you have an important update of a canine
identity
the exile of biden's dog major
apparently the first dog was sent
packing to delaware after a little
incident the first family's younger dog
major was surprised by an unfamiliar
person
and reacted in a way that resulted in a
minor injury to the individual